I can’t wait to move into Gridiron Heights!
You guys are all f--king mistakes.
We’re here! Starters first!
KNEEL BEFORE ME, ROOKIE SCUM!
Nick!
Buddy, you know I’m coming back.
Ok, well, thanks, everyone.
This was SO much fun while it lasted.
Gridiron Heights has never been stronger.
Rebuilding is so fun.
The Jets have been doing it for years!
Helmet to helmet!
Yeah, we’re not rebuilding.
Yes you are.
I can clearly see you restructuring everything.
Yeah, no. Nothing’s changed.
We’re still really good.
Jimmy, are you going to help me?
Nah, just build around me.
Finally! Our rebuild is over.
Hey! I’m not hurt this time!
Soon enough, Sammy.
Just hit the nail, Hue.
The nail may not get hammered....
...but Browns fans certainly will.
The Patriots do not rebuild...
We reload.
Um, Coach, are we cool?
No.